- C'es
et légumes au Marché public
de Sainte-Foy, à Québec,
que Dominique Anglade veut
illustrer une contradiction :
l'inflation pénalise
les Québécois, tandis qu'elle
profite au gouvernement.
Parti libéral du Québec
- Pendant que les coffres
du gouvernement Legault
se remplissent, les poches
des Québécois se vident.isisisi,
Dominique Anglade promet
quatre mililliards de dollars
en mesures. Elle bonifierait
de 25 % le crédit d'impôt
la TVQ sur les produits
p première nécessité,
comme du savon, et les Québécois
sur les premiers 4000 $
de leur facture d'électricité.
D'ailleurs, elle gèlerait
- C'est 5000 $ dans la poche
de votre famille!
- Elle choisit de faire l l l l-
Nationale, quie e compte plus de
député libéral, et en l'absence.
Est-ce quvovous avez perdu
votre titre de parti de
de le regagner?
- Je pense qu'on a aucunement
perdu ce titre-là, au contraire.
s'engagent à redonner 1125 $
par année aux contribuables
en diminuant les impôts
de 1,5 % pour imimimimimimimimit
renchérit avec une promesse
similaire, sauf que, lui,
les diminuerait de 1 % dès 2023,
pour quelqu'un qui gagne
un salaire de 80 000 par année.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT, chef,
- On ne va pas avec
un gouvernement de la CAQ,
retourner à l'austérité
ERIC GIRARD, ministre
des Finances sortant, Québec
- C'est une approche équilibrép.
- Pour financer la baisse
d'impôt de deux milliards
de dollars par année,
d'historique, il réduira
les contributions auononds
des générations, dont l'objectif
est de réduire l
- On est des conservateurs
fiscaux.
- Éric Duhaime rappelle qu'il a
proposé
payer d'impôts sur les premiers
2020 000 $ gagnés, plutôt
que les 15 000 premiers,
Il le financera, entre autres,
en permettant l'exploitation
des hydrocarbures au Québec.
Parti conservateur du Québec
- Pour nous, c'estnene source
de revenu supplémentaire
qui va apparaître dans
- On vous dérange-tu
un petit peu?
- La surenchère s'est poursuivie
plus tard dans la journéltltltlé
le montant du deuxième chèque
envoyé à plus de 6 millions
de Québécois d'ici la fin
de l'année. Entre lelelelelelel.
- C'est important d'aider
les Québécois. C'est important
de faire face à l'inflation.
- Là, re
promesse va s'effectuer ou pas.
- Ils raraient mieux de nous
baisser la taxe tout court sur
le
(acclamation)
LeLes chefs de parti ont sondé
leurs troupes avant de partir
Diminuer le coût de la vie
s'avère la priorité
d'une majorité de Québécois.
convaincus que l'argent ira bel
et bien dans leurs poche